do you think that hot girls are more
crazy always do you think hot girls are
more crazy in your own experience as
well I've been around quite a few hot
girls but some of them can be very
balanced but I give me your treaties on
hot girls being crazy here's what it is
with a very attractive women they don't
get an insight into the average man and
how average men behave they get an
insight into men that are incredibly
intimidated by their beauty or
incredibly lustful after their beauty so
they see men either kind of ignore them
so the quiet good guys either just kind
of intimidated by them but the loud
gregarious kind of adulterous men are
after them so they'll see guys that will
leave their wives to be with you they'll
see guys that will uh drop everything to
kind of you know even if their
girlfriend's in the same room they're
quickly sneaking you their number
they'll see guys that will risk their
jobs you know if they're your boss to be
with you so they see men as these huge
Risk Takers that will do anything to
have sex with you so what ends up
happening is she loses her naivity about
a man she no longer thinks men are
faithful she's seen so many men break up
whatever they have just to be with you
and just to access you she's seen so
many men who break their back just to
touch you so what happens is when her
husband now says to her oh I'm just
there's a new colleague at work her
brain is like well every colleague at my
work is always hit on me are you hitting
on this girl or if if her husband says
I'm just going to the gym she's like
well whenever I go to the gym somebody
hits on me what are you doing so they
end up being suspicious because they are
privie to men at their worst when
they're sexually attracted to a woman
they don't have that naivity that a more
plain woman would have where she could
walk past a guy in a bikini and he
doesn't harass her she knows if she
walks past a guy in a bikini drops
everything so she sees men as more
dangerous than they are and therefore
she thinks her partner is more sexual
than he might be and as a result she
tends to be more intense and crazy and
less naive but not necessar more
accusatory I would say yeah because she
uses her experience about the world to
predict what everybody else's
experiences about the world and in her
defense beautiful women also it takes a
certain level of confidence and and a
certain level of no fear rejection to
access a beautiful girl so her pool of
men tend to be the men that are more
likely to be unfaithful wow that's
interesting so very attractive women are
a selection effect for the kinds of
experiences that they have in life the
kinds of interactions that they have
with other women and other men so
presumably they'll often see other women
as threats well they well they've
experienced other women seeing them as
threats and they've seen the competitive
nature of women and they've seen women
cuz here the thing with beautiful women
if you walk into a room with a really
beautiful woman all the other beautiful
women will now start looking at you
thinking well there must be something
about I'm sure they look at you anyway
but they would pay more attention
because there must be something about
Chris because she's unbelievable so what
ends up happening is beautiful women
start to see how disrespectful other
women can be they're looking at your man
they're they're competing with you
because to get a beautiful woman's man
makes the other women feel more
attractive if you walk in with an
absolutely 12 out of 10 and then you
give me attention I now think I'm
prettier than her so so therefore I want
your attention more than the guy that's
with the girl that's not that attractive
so we see this competitive nature of
women we see that we can put men women
can put men on the map and they see that
men are very soft and they give into
Beauty quite quickly and easily so they
leads to a trust issue that is harder to
kind of overcome so interesting the
psychology of an attractive woman is one
that is very different to a psychology
of a less attractive woman they're two
different species yeah so you have women
seeing other women primarily as enemies
they're often going to be Frosty to them
they're also kind of hyper aware of the
power that they can bestow on the
partner that they're with which probably
makes them a little bit tentative about
giving that man that power because if
they pre-select that particular type of
man you're putting him on the map yep
and then you also said that these
women being super attractive selects for
a very specific type of guy that is
sufficiently confident to go up and
speak to you or men will make ridiculous
and wild u-turns in their life in an
attempt to get to you which also gives
you a pretty
unrepresentative experience of what most
men are like yeah on and then when the
look start to fade it's a harder
transition for them when the look start
to fade from a woman who is quite plain
she sees it as life when the look start
to fade um with an attractive woman she
sees it as disastrous because a lot of
the power has gone so they might not
always but they they might respond to it
with a lot more insecurity especially
after children but if she has good
values she recognizes that though the
looks are replaced with family
connection but if she doesn't have good
values and her identity is built on her
appearance you'll see that she'll go
through more and more extents to kind of
um prove her attractiveness and that
might lead to promiscuity so her
identity can't be designed and around
her looks it will make her very fragile
it's rough yeah being an attractive
woman must be hard like genuinely it
must be very difficult to try and go
through the world because with men
typically their value to the world
doesn't wax and Wayne in quite the same
way you know it starts off low even
super attractive guys will remain being
attractive for a very long time forever
like and you just have this sort of slow
and steady increase presumably and then
it'll dip out and then it'll start to
even afterwards and when it dips you
don't care if it dips by that time
you're so settled in life you don't care
but for women it can di a lot earlier
and um there's a lot of talk about
pretty privilege and pretty privilege
this and pretty privilege that but
there's lots of disadvantages and the
main thing is people look for your flaws
a lot more what happens when you're not
attractive is people can accept what
you're saying and doing and they don't
really delve into it but when you're
attractive there's an element of other
women or even men saying well I bet
she's dumb well I bet she's a hoe or I
bet they're looking for the negative so
much more and then all they'll say I bet
she's really arrogant and very vain so
you almost have to work against people's
negative assumptions of your character
as much as they make positive
assumptions of your appearance they make
lots of negative assumptions about your
character so you're in a bit of a battle
and then it's not as easy as it might
look to other people I saw what I was a
model for a decade and a half in the UK
and I saw a lot of the girls almost
counter signal they would turn up in the
most slouchy clothes that they could um
you know they would purpose wear their
hair up they would purposefully wear
glasses um they wouldn't wear revealing
clothes they would uh try and act in
ways that were um more bookish sometimes
as well and this could just be their
personality it could have been the girls
that I was around but I also think there
might be something going on here that
they're trying to counter signal I am
more than just what I'm currently being
paid for as a part of my career I'm more
than just a pretty face I'm more than
just a lingerie model I'm more than just
someone that's supposed to smile and
gigg and look nice on camera and is it
hard for men to realize that they're
more than that or is it hard for them to
like do they can they compartmentalize
and think that she's got more to good
question do they do they get
overwhelmingly like attached to her
appearance so there's a big difference
between Beauty and hotness and most
models at least the ones that I was
working with it wasn't sort of Glamour
stuff or underwar stuff that much it was
you know like fashion stuff it was like
cutesy editorial Girl Next Door type
thing so it was probably optimizing more
for beauty than it was for
yeah um and but certainly when it comes
to hotness it's a [__] reality
Distortion field for men right and this
is what we were say this is the word
that was coming to my mind as you were
talking about this that the reality of a
a very very hot woman is like a sphere
that follows around her just distorting
all of her experiences with women with
men at restaurants getting into
nightclubs with careers everything yeah
the super hot sexy woman gets it
probably the wor worse because they
activate a man's short-term mating
strategies they have long-term mating
strategies with who they want to family
with and short-term who they just want
to mate with and they activate that in
uh men so a really sexy girl will
activate a man's short-term mating
strategies and she'll also activate
threats in women now women's ual threats
um when they when they're threatened
with a woman is to go prot well suggest
that she's promiscuous so they might say
to them to the men oh yeah but she's
really promiscous not realizing that
actually makes her more attractive to
them cuz they're like well I'm already
looking for a shortterm promiscous
trying to sell yeah so they think that
they're actually undermining her by
saying she's so promiscuous and she's a
[__] and she's this that and the other
but the man when his short-term meeting
strategies are activated that's exactly
what he's looking for so she ends up
with men who just want short-term
meeting strategies and as a result she
starts to see men as seeing disposable
and therefore it can it can be really
negative for the hot woman um it does
make sense about why it would be hard to
have a normal a normal mindset I'm aware
that it's e Anderson effect yeah it's
easy to throw shade like our hot girl's
crazy like it's easy to just throw shade
at them but what this is why I I like
these kinds of conversations because it
really helps everybody to understand the
experienced psychology you know the
lived experience of somebody that's on
that side of the fence and you can say
yeah pretty privilege the halo effect
you know she's getting in for free at
nightclubs and blah blah blah it's like
yeah but what if she's got zero female
friends what if she can't find a female
friend that doesn't see her as an enemy
or an adversary or a competitor what if
every single guy that she spends time
with is terrified to speak to her or is
it's just it's so interesting so on the
other side of the fence do you think
it's more difficult for successful or
desirable men to settle down it's only
difficult when they grew up without
valid when they've got low self-esteem
for men their success in with
relationships is very much determined by
their self-esteem women can get a
shortcut with their appearance and so on
and so forth for men the self-esteem is
either going to propel them into a great
relationship or U prevent them from any
kind of stability now if he grew up
without any validation and not knowing
if he was attractive what happens is his
self-esteem is almost um blocked at that
stage of life and then he can still be a
sucker to women and still kind of accept
the unacceptable simply because he wants
to be desired but if he has good
self-esteem and good boundaries he will
never suffer in relationships he just
won't because he knows when he's welcome
he knows when he's not accepted and when
when the relationship is not working and
he has a willingness to walk away so the
the thing is money with low self-esteem
is really really difficult it's a very
lonely path it's a lot of gold diggers
it's a lot of escorts it's a lot of
partying even at the Olden age now money
with high self-esteem and um good values
is you mean it's still difficult but you
you you can create something out of that
what about successful women they
struggle they they really struggle
because essentially with successful
women here's the thing men always say oh
when women earn more they leave men but
they don't realize why there's actually
studies to show that when men are with
women that earn more than them they
produce more cortisol they're actually
more angry and stressed around her and
that obviously has a negative impact on
their testosterone so they're actually
less sexually attracted to her and so
they're meaner to her they're mean and
also they don't treat her the same way
if a man is dating a woman who know he
knows is unemployed say if he's on
20,000 a year he'll still use whatever
he has to treat her well like you know
look after but if he's on 20,000 a year
and she's on 50,000 you use nothing to
invest in her now women don't need your
money but they do need your investment
because that's how men fall in love the
more they invest in something the more
they attach to it if they invest a lot
of money in a car they really care about
it lost a lot of money into a Bitcoin
they want to see it go up invest money
into a Woman They want to see it work
out so when they are with a woman that
earns more they invest so little so
walking away seems so easy for them and
it seems so hard for her because she's
been the one that's investing in them so
it's very difficult it's not just the
woman who's rich and now she leaves you
the man no longer adds any value that is
the main issue he doesn't use whatever
tiny resources he has on the woman like
he normally would every single morning
for over 3 years now I have started my
day the exact same way which is with
element in water element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium pottassium and magnesium and it
is the best hydration drink that I've
ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and ried on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a nobs no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element are giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you to
the link in the description box below or
drink LM nt.com
/mw that's drink lnt.com
/mw what's happening people if you
enjoyed that then press here for the
full unedited episode and don't forget
to
subscribe